When you start working on your app,
one of the worst things that you
can do is re-invent the wheel.
And by that I mean, by using code that's
already been written by someone else.
The beauty of the internet is that
there's a plethora of information about
there that you can take from.
>From Apple libraries that let
you use features on the device,
to web APIs that allow you to
access information on other sites.
So it's going to be your job as
a developer to really scrutinize
any web API or library that
you find to really make sure
that it meets the requirements
of your apps.
Let's sync up again with some
of our pros for some tips and
tricks on how to choose the best API and
library